今天要是平呀,不是面对所有人的,它是针对一部分人,就是江湖说的老伙似,而且不太容易理解,你可能需要反复多看两遍,所以如果不是特别喜欢的小伙伴,你就让行吧,不要浪费这个事件,首先我们说的是一个老生长谈的问题,有前两天,有小伙伴,就问了,说胡子哥,人和人的差距到底是什么,其实这个张亦名,它是有一个,
但是我来说一下我的这个理解,首先你的出生人卖资源,其实是很重要的,有些时候你我能力,但是没有机会,有些没有能力,但是通过这样一个机会,它便能有能力的,但是这几个因素你没有办法做选择,我们可以做选择什么呢,一个就是,就是你认知,然后你去做选择,基于认知做选择,对吧,就是我们说有句话就,
你怕假错了,你选择行业选的城市不会是,那你这个人时候方向就可能出现问题,所以这个许案则很重要,那么张亦名就话就很重要了,就之前有人问他,他说人和人的差距,文件是认知,是从这来的,因为认知究竟你的许案则,好,那么第二件是和这个事有关,你的许案则对不对,对不对,对不对,方向是不是合理的,你的方向如果错了就很麻烦了,
但是如果方向是对的,你看很多人就在原别拉墨,而那你是我方向的,每天哪怕是没周,往前躲一点这个差别就很大,可是你怎么保证你的方向是正确的呢,首先你要知道你所在的那条大传玩,实相那个方向,但是这个传玩的方向也不是完全有传决定的,他可能有作为的环境,天气地缘决定的,所以你必须看,
但天,就你需要知道整个国际的形势,然后在决定我们这个大传往哪去走,那么怎么看,我们是有受限的,那么有两个方法,一个方法的话呢,就是你要知道一些智能一些智库,就他们的观点,就有些时候一个文件,一个绝侧出来,对不对吧,他不是说简单,那就是我一拍闹的,他时候很多的智能,在一起谈套的,你想我们过去啊,主工我要做和绝侧,
不是,那模式给祝很多建议,反复四样反复四号,下这么一个去错,所以一个文件出来可能只有那么一两句话,文件嘛,对吧,他要言计,所以只能走那么一两句话,但是那一两句话他背后可能是很多智能,就他们的观点,所以你可以找到这些智能,就他们可能有一些设论,或者有一些书,有一些文章你是可以看的,这是一类,还有一类的话呢,就以前是在
到他们的,后来的话呢,下野了,对吧,现在再也不能下野,你比如说举了一次,以前有一个叫三墨丝的,他以前是漂亮的前才长,后来到哈佛大学,当校长,那么现在每个政策出来的话呢,他就会有这个评论,那么可以是三墨丝,还可以是某个周的周长,某个市的市长,某个行行长,对吧,你就可以找到这样的一些人物,看他他们的观点,
这些观点出来以后的话呢,你不要完全相信,就好像我有很多很多的智能,各种感到声音,努力思考很重要了,那么当一个观点出来的时候,那么我们要看他的论聚,是事实还是观点,是不是正确的,对吧,是不是真是存在的,然后他的论聚,他的论证,是不是合理,进步进步的起推销,有没有什么漏洞,这样一个过程,听到很多很多声音,这个时候你再看那个文章,
你先和解册,你去对应,那么你的诗言,你的这个思考的模式就不压了,就是我们说第二个,那我现在的话呢,就是从现在到过年,其实我一直参考这些人的观点,然后来看,我认为我未来一言,我的大方向,莫莫忽忽的,应该是什么样子的,那么第三个方面的话呢,就是你有这么一个方向,这个方向不一定是对的,对吧,虽然有很多参考,
但是他不一定是正确的,有些时候那个角色都不一定是正确的,所以这个时候的话呢,有一个东西很重要了,还记得吗,每天花一个两个小时,一个小时会两个小时,去做那个最重要的事,每天都会,每天在想这个最重要的事的时候,你就要看这个大方向,因为我要做的是,每天望那个方向去揉动,他不一定是正确的,但是我,你是不是有点今天要做什么,然后呢,去做反思,重新看方向,不断地去教育,第二天接得如此,
有些人是每天,有些人做不到每天,你可能每周,但是不断地教育,那他和你每天在缘地拉墨和每周往前挪一步,是不是太阳了,通过这三点的话,大家再看,我今年年初跟大家说,我二人三年的计划,你可能就明白,我在说什么了,